Fiona un nom familier des amateurs de
The Voice l'émission musicale de TF1 la
tourangelle de 16 ans crève l'écran
grâce à sa voix et son charisme
exceptionnel de main place au fameux
battle qui doivent permettre de la
départager entre deux enregistrements
l'adolescente élève au Conservatoire de
Tours nous a reçu chez elle Sarah gros
[Musique]
tente douce et magique c'est la voix de
Fiona
[Musique]
ou neveu
quand ce n'est pas sur scène c'est dans
sa chambre que la jeune lycéenne de 16
ans passe la majorité de son temps à
chanter une amartistique qu'elle
développe depuis sa plus tendre enfance
à 10 ans elle intègre le conservatoire
de Tours c'est laquelle développe sa
passion pour la musique un amour qui
depuis ne l'a jamais quitté et lorsque
je passe une très très bonne journée je
vais mettre de la musique à fond pour
pouvoir danser parce que c'est comme ça
que j'exprimais ma joie et je suis pas
la seule mais c'est comme ça où je me
sens vraiment super bien et moi-même et
lorsque ce que je suis triste où j'ai
passé une mauvaise journée ben j'ai
juste à me mettre à mon piano et puis
improviser ou même chanter une musique
qui me qui me touche particulièrement et
c'est là que tout s'échappe c'est c'est
vraiment un refuge en fait c'est un
cocon
entre concours de chant représentation
et comédie musicale Fiona attire
l'attention des mélomanes sa voix
prometteuse lui a ouvert les portes de
l'émission The Voice un rêve éveillé
qu'elle partage avec sa famille je
l'encourage je le pousse je suis
derrière elle en fait et je suis
toujours avec elle pour qu'elle arrive à
réaliser ses rêves on va pas dire que je
réalise pas mais ça reste quand même
encore de la télé je vois pas je vois
pas encore tout ce qui tout ce qui peut
se passer bien que on me reconnaît de
temps en temps dans la rue je signe des
autographes je fais des photos on sourit
ou souvent j'entends des ah mais c'est
pas la vie de The Voice ça ce genre de
truc si son succès décolle qu'il y en a
n'en garde pas moins les pieds sur terre
et maintient le cap sur une de ses
priorités le bac de français en fin
d'année
qu'un jour sur deux dans les chansons
s'émerveilleux mais dans la vie c'est
vraiment triste
[Musique]